hi guys I told you I was gonna vlog to
show you all the cool things that I do
outside of YouTube and right now I'm in
Cambridge for a workshop thing to do
with my ratify project so I thought I'd
take you with me and i'm here with with
some some weird people oh there it is
yes she is me it that's muddy that one
and that's that I can't do this and
that's Owen hey hey let's go let's pipe
this man
Maddie staircases moving your wheel
we're here at tight ratify headquarters
we're listening to some sonic PI force
you buy new green she double Salmon oh
and there's Maddie Shh way
this house feels like getting pop-up
lessons from Maddie because she's an
animation pop of the expert honey yeah
that's why I'm using mikes of paint
right now what's your youtube channel
Maddie turned against liking me
subscribe
now what do i do Maddie you just you
just cut along the lines so you cut
along the straight line but long
straight lines for long the little air
the dirty fold along the dirty oh wow
that's so cool I love this
got the event frightened footage I'm
putting this in the blog post okay
that's fine that looks good we're making
progress how does the real pissed do I
need I think the blog post is done I
think look oh yes you knew last you ever
knew work subscription blog post and I
don't like I never know which I'm always
gonna say obviously from yourself you
ask me know because Vaz oh oh so far we
have written a blog post about the
exhibition and right now we're going to
be installing openframeworks on new SD
cards that we've gotten little open your
terminal was opened awesome and then do
LS actually no you don't need to be
pretty handy that this shows you your
files okay so then and then CD and then
open forever into that folder you'll see
so yes let's go another step so now if
you view and LS so you will see you into
that students CD into that wait wait
wait what are you doing what is it
commander it's basically you know when
you do anything in the terminal it's
pretty much what you do when you're
looking through your folder system
anyway so it's just a different way yeah
great day what up what is that up what
are you doing what do you do anything
Gucci you'd be your to echuca happy she
looks he has been sleeping so I just
like to say oh you're all very lucky oh
that's such a wonderful person I
coexists and this xvideos be didn't know
i don't think i have opposed very
creative the cheapest a lot of effort
into them I don't mean it's obvious you
can see from this era and your white
even saw the how to enjoy them it's a
good job keep Dana o Canada way cool I
don't really her I one you in folly I
know how do I found this in edit and
genuinely nearly cried it's so freaking
cute
I'm back from Cambridge I got back super
fast I had to rush because we're filming
neck lemak it's nina and it's Rivero and
it's vitamins oh and it's that guy I'm
try andis to floor for that long it's
for the vlog this will tell you put
cables together very well
are you doing yells man I know high five
to that alright how're you finding fun
i'm not very much in the way
this my new t-shirt wait damn son a
better bit more you go on yeah keep
going bits of this for keep going are
you going there you go 50p what's the
problem yazma this a vga adapter will
not update with the mac update i think
it's because it's not a proper mac one
hmm but i'll try and i'll transfer over
the weekend what's your final thought
I'm gonna take this home on my honor I
think it just caught I wanna make it
work okay did it cut off nope okay it's
about to I'm gonna have dinner you're
gonna have dinner yeah I already have my
sentence hey I am back home now I am
feeling lazy I am fear sluggish with
[ __ ] oh and I'll turn our top so it's
been an amazing day I wanted to do more
of these vlogs just to show you what I
do when I'm not doing my normal youtube
videos because especially recently
Abedin like a law and I feel bad because
I want to make more videos for you but
then I was just like late why don't i
vlog them so now you guys get to see my
other interests and kind of what I do
what I enjoyed today was a bit of an odd
one I'm sorry I'm still getting used to
this vlogging Milwaukee my time with
Rossi pie was fun got to do a bit more
my project got to learn more butter from
frameworks and all that jazz got to
learn how to make a pop-up book which is
awesome thank you Mary and then I got
back home and I was trying to set up a
surge actor for my friends didn't work
out but I got it to work I took it home
and I got it to work and so there's
gonna be some projection videos coming
very very soon and I'm pretty excited
about that yes I knew it have a lovely
day or evening bye
hi guys i am in germany and look at this
awesome hostel it looks so cool it's a
hospital in clone where all the hostels
are themed and this one's themed as a
ballerina Oh room